GOOD MORNING WILL BEGIN TODAY'S
SIMPLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION FINANCE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY.
HERE
CHAVEZ CARE.
MEDINA.
VOEPEL.
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED O'DONNELL.
OKAY GOOD MORNING.
THESE ARE HIGHER EDUCATION
ITEMS TODAY VOTE ONLY KNOW.
PUBLIC COMMENT VOTE ONLY AND
DISCUSSION ON OUR MAJOR ACTIONS.
IS AGAIN THIS IS THE HIGHER
EDUCATION AT PEACE ABSENT THAT
TWO ISSUES ONE OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
SECTIONS NOT TODAY THAT'S IN
THE PROP NINETY EIGHT HEARING
WILL SPEAK TOMORROW. AND WE ARE
I'M NOT HEARING THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. ITEMS TODAY OF
THOSE ITEMS WILL BE HEARD LATER
IN THE WEEK.
SO ANYBODY HERE FOR YOU SEE
ISSUES THOSE WILL BE ADDRESSED
LATER.
IN THE WEEK THAT WITH THAT'S.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH THEIR VOTE ONLY
ITEMS WILL START WITH THE.
.
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE THE CALIFORNIA
CASE WHO LEARNING LATIN.
GOVERNOR THE GOVERNOR'S UP
BUDGET PROPOSAL.
THIS DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
YOU JACQUI GOV.
YOU WANT TO JUST VOTE ON THE
WHOLE.
IT'S ONE.
POSTED LOOK AT HARTMAN BY.
YEAH I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT SO
WE'RE GOING TO AS OPPOSED DOING
THE PACKAGE WE'RE GONNA DO.
DEPARTMENT BY BIKE BY
DEPARTMENT SO THAT FIRST IS THE.
OFFICE OF A PLANNING AND
RESEARCH IN THIS IS THAT.
LEARNING LAB PROPOSAL. THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND USE THE
FUNDS TO FIND THAT CSU
ENROLLMENT WE HAVE A MOTION.
YOU CHAIR MOVE ALL MOVED TO
REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S VOTE
BUDGET PROPOSAL.
OKAY MOTION SECOND PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MCCARTY.
I.
CHAVEZ I.
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL I.
VOEPEL.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
IS THAT CALIFORNIA'S CASH
UPAZILAS AUTHORITY LOOKING FOR A
MOTION TO APPROVE THE MAY REVISE
PROPOSAL A MOVE. MAY REVEAL
CLOSE SECOND MOTION A SECOND
PLEASE CALL.
MCCARTY. CHáVEZ ALRIGHT.
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL. AYE VOEPEL.
OKAY THE NEXT SET OF ISSUES WAY
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY.
LOOKING FOR.
A MOTION TO APPROVE THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ISSUES.
THREE THREE SIXTEEN EXCEPT FOR
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AND WE WILL DO
THAT SEPARATELY PER THE
REPUBLICANS REQUEST ALL MOVE.
DONE THAT RECOMMENDATION.
SECOND.
VERY MUCH RESPECT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY. OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ISSUES THREE
THROUGH SIXTEEN ABSENT NUMBER
EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MCCARTY. AYE AYE.
CHAVEZ.
ORDER CLARIFICATION UP WITHOUT A
WE VOTE AND I DID FIFTEEN AS A
YES OR NO.
YOU SAY ONE THING FIFTEEN ONE
FOR SIXTEEN.
THREE WE NEED TO PULL FIFTEEN
OUT THAT AFFECTS AND AS WELL
OKAY.
SO WE'RE VOTING ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS LISTA NEEDS AND
ITEMS THREE THROUGH SIXTEEN
ISSUE THREE THROUGH SIXTEEN
ABSOLUTE NUMBERS.
EIGHT AND FIFTEEN THAT'S CORRECT
OKAY.
WE ARE REVISED THAT MOTION BY.
MISTER DOT MR MEDINA AND SECOND
BY MR DOT.
MCCARTY I.
CHáVEZ ALRIGHT.
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
OKAY.
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY ISSUE
NUMBER GATES.
THIS IS THE.
ELIMINATION OF THE SUNSET.
ON THE F. FOR PROFIT LIBRARY
SERVICES LOOKING FOR A MOTION TO
APPROVE. PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO ELIMINATE THE
SUNSET IN THE AT CUT.
EVERY MOTION A SACK HIT THE SIDE
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MCCARTY BY CHáVEZ NO.
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
YES ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY RELATED
TO.
ORAL HISTORIES LOOKING FOR A
MOTION TO APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AB PLUS THERE'S NO ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ONE TIME
TO SUPPORT THE ORAL HISTORY
PROJECT MOVE.
MOTION A SECOND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MCCARTY AYE.
CHáVEZ NO.
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
WE DO HAVE ONE.
OKAY.
THEY WERE DOING WE ARE DOING ONE.
MINOR YOU SEE ACTION.
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTEEN.
REAPPROPRIATION THAT THE E. L.
PASSED THROUGH FEDERAL FUNDS
THE INFORMATION I AM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN ON THE LIVES OF.
MUCH IN THE SECOND THIS IS A
CORRECTION THAT IBM SIXTEEN.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY.
NOT.
OKAY.
WE HAVE NUMBER ISSUES
SURE MULTI ABOUT THAT.
MCCARTY BY.
CHAVEZ NINE.
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
YOU KNOW ALREADY HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO.
UC HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW.
ISSUES NUMBER EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN. LOOKING FAR.
MOTION TO APPROVE THESE TO
ISOLATE TO THE GOVERNOR'S NOT A
PROBLEM AND I DON'T SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
SEC.
A MOTION A SECOND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW.
MCCARTY AYE. CHáVEZ VALLEY
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
OKAY.
WILL PROCEED NOW WITH THAT CSU
AND AND WE HAVE TO CSU SECTIONS
THIS IS JUST THE VOTE ONLY
PIECES.
AND LOOKING FOR A MOTION NOW ON.
CS YOU ISSUES NUMBER.
TWENTY TWO THREE TWENTY THREE.
INVESTING LANGUAGE INVESTMENTS
REPORT FINANCIALLY REPORTS.
AND FELLOW SAX MASTER
AUGMENTATION.
SECOND.
OKAY MOTION A SECOND ISSUES
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE CSU
MCCARTY AYE.
CHáVEZ ALRIGHT. MEDINA.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR THIS
THE CSU EDUCATION POLICY
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM.
LOOKING FOR A MOTION TO APPROVE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
MCCARTY.
I CHáVEZ KNOW.
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
OKAY GETS THEM.
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS FOR THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION.
ISSUES TWENTY FIVE
THROUGH TWENTY SEVEN MOVE
APPROVAL ITEMS TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN.
DR SECOND.
SECOND.
OKAY. MCCARTY AYE AYE CHáVEZ
AYE.
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU.
NOW WILL PROCEED TO THE.
THE CSU BUDGET PACKAGE THAT WE.
.
SPENT SEVERAL.
MONTHS DISCUSSING THROUGH OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS.
TALKING ABOUT ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY ISSUES MR MEDINA.
WHO WERE ON
STUDENTS?
THAT'S COMING RIGHT HERE I'M IN
ATLANTA RIGHT NOW FOR CSU.
THAT WE HAD EARLIER THE CSU VOTE
ONLY AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO.
FOCUS ON THE CSU OVERALL BUDGET
PACKAGE THAT WE WANT TO.
AUGMENTIN ADDITION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S I'M A REVISED BUDGET.
THAT PROPOSAL SELF. THAT WE
ESSENTIALLY YOU KNOW HEARD FROM
CSU STUDENTS AND. FACULTY AND
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE SYSTEM ABOUT
THEM.
ARE CSU TWENTY THREE.
A SEGMENT CAMPUS REC CALIFORNIA
AND AND REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE GOT PROBABLY GOT FUND. THAT
THAT THE CSU SYSTEM SO WITH THAT
WE HAVE A PROPOSAL HERE TO FULLY
FUND THE CSU REQUESTS.
A INCREASE ENROLLMENT A GROWTH
TO ENSURE MORE QUALIFIED
STUDENTS FIND A SPOT.
SEE IF YOU THINK IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE THAT.
THIRTY THOUSAND CSU STUDENTS
QUALIFIED EVERY YEAR.
APPLY AND OUR TONIGHT ADMISSION
SO.
OUR OUR PROPOSAL WILL FUNDS
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
NEW.
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES FOR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE CSU SYSTEM
AROUND THREE PERCENT ENROLLMENT
GROWTH. THAT WE ALSO CALL ON CS
YOU TAKE A STEP TOWARDS
IMPROVING. GRADUATION RATES.
BY INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
TENURE TRACK FACULTY ON OUR
CAMPUSES.
NOW WE ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT THEM
CSU STUDENTS BY CONTINUING OUR
STUDENT HUNGER. PROGRAMS AND.
SUPPORTING A NEW EMERGENCY
HOUSING PILOT PROJECT DEALING
WITH STUDENTS WHO NEED TO HELP
THEM MAKE SURE.
THEY HAVE THE GETA.
HIGHER EDUCATION SUCCESS
SO WITH THAT.
THE.
AT THEATTIRE PACKAGE JUST
OUTLINED ON PAGE EIGHTEEN OF THE
AGENDA.
AND LOOKING FOR A MOTION ON THE
PACKAGE MR MEDINA.
YES SIR ITEM.
AND ROSE WROTE YES HOUSES TO.
WHAT IS THE DOLLAR?
THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS WELL THAT THE.
THAT
.
YEAH IS THERE A REASON.
WELL THE IT'S THE OVERALL THAT
PACKAGE THAT WERE FUNDING TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN ABOVE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND OTHER TWO
FIFTEEN. WE FIND TEN THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED. AND EAT THEY EACH
CSU STUDENTS EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS ROUGHLY SO THAT'S HOW WE
MAKE THAT CALCULATION.
EIGHTY NINE POINT FIVE THAT.
CORRECT.
YET WE THINK IT'S SUFFICIENT
DOING THE. OVERALL GENERAL FUND.
ALLOCATION ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND SPECIFY HOW MANY
ENROLLMENT SLOTS WE.
TO ASSUME A CSU WELLA.
IS THIS A CSU HAVE HAVE PROPER.
INSTRUCTIONS AND DIRECTION FROM
AN ACTION.
AS THE AND NOT FROM THEM SO.
WITH THAT LOOKING FOR A OUT WILL
FIRST MONEY DISCUSSION QUESTIONS.
I BELIEVE I.
I BELIEVE ITEM FOR SOME DIDN'T
GOES A BILL TO PULL THAT OUT SO
WE CAN VOTE IN. A NOTED THAT
EVERYTHING ELSE.
THEY CERTAINLY SUPPORTING NOT.
BORN IN.
SURE THE INCREASE SEVEN TENURE
TRACK FACULTY WANT TO. PULL THAT
ITEM OUT MISTER TRAVIS IS PLEASE.
THEY HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY SEEING SEEING.
NO MORE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WILL WILL HAVE.
YEAH
I'M I MOVE APPROVAL SHE ISSUE
BUDGET PACKAGE ITEMS ONE.
THROUGH THE LAB AND JUST PULLING
OUT ITEM FORCE VOGON SEPARATELY.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT.
BUSH IN THE SECOND.
MCCARTY.
GUY
CHAVEZ I.
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL.
LIMON.
VOEPEL.
THANK YOU LOOKING FOR A
SECONDARY MOTION NOW FOR THE
ITEM RELATE TO THE FULL TIME
FACULTY AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT TO FIFTEEN TO
ENSURE THAT WE CREASE THE NUMBER
AT. TENURE TRACK FACULTY EACH
CAMPUS.
BEST MOTION A SECOND BY MR
MEDINA AND MISS POLLY MOUNT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MCCARTY.
I CHAVEZ NO.
LIMON.
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL NO.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT.
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
ADDRESS THIS TO NEED COMMISSION.
EARLIER PURSUE DRASTIC
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS FROM THE
MAY REVISED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
AND HERE IS GONNA. LOOK AT SOME
JUST BECAUSE OF A AYE EDITIONS.
.
TO DO THAT.
YOU NO WE HAD A A ROBUST
CONVERSATION ON FINANCIAL AID.
S. YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
SHORTCOMINGS OF OUR FINANCIAL A
KNOWING THAT OUR FINANCIAL AID
COVERS. FOR NEARLY HALF A
MILLION STUDENTS SITUATION BUT
KNOWING THE COST OF COLLEGE IS
MUCH MORE THAN TUITION THESE
DAYS AND. HOUSING BOOKS IN
TRANSPORTATION AND FOOD SO LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING A MORE ROBUST
CONVERSATIONS ON FINANCIAL AID
REFORM TO TO ADDRESS THEM. AT
THOSE ISSUES.
SO THAT NO MAJOR ACTION THERE
FOR THAT BUT WE DO. WANT TO.
.
APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO.
IN ADDITION TO MAINTAIN THAT
THAT THE CAL GRANT AWARD FOR
NONPROFITS.
AT NINE THOUSAND EIGHTY FOR AS
LONG AS THE SECTORS INCREASE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFERS.
THIS ACTION RESOLVE THE
LONGSTANDING ISSUE AND HOPEFULLY
PUTS THIS THIS THAT THIS ITEM TO
REST AFTER A NUMBER OF YEARS. WE
ALSO.
OKAY.
AND WE ALSO.
WENT TO.
.
SPEAKING OF THE.
INDEPENDENT AND AT COLLEGE IS.
OUTSIDE THE U. C. INSIDIOUS YOU
WE WANT TO.
REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
ACTIONS REDUCE THE MAXIM CALVERT
AWARD FOR STUDENTS ATTENDING
WASCO CREDITED FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES.
AND LIKE WE DID WITH THE
NONPROFITS WE WANTED THESE
COLLEGES TO DO SOMETHING A STEP
UP TO TO HELP.
AND THE STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE ASKING THEM
AND THEY'VE AGREED TO.
THAT PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE LANGUAGE SETTING ASIDE
THIS AWARD AMOUNTS OF NINE
THOUSAND EIGHTY FOUR. IF EACH
SECTOR ADMITS MORE TO STUDENTS.
OR OFFERS INSTITUTIONALLY TO
THEIR CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS.
AND THEN.
TO MORE ITEMS.
WE ARE EXPANDING THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM FOR FOSTER YOUTH
ALLOWING THEM TO STAY IN THE CAL
GRANT.
A SYSTEM FOR UP TO EIGHT YEARS
ALLOWING THEM TO QUALIFY FOR THE
ENTITLEMENT CALTRAIN UNTIL
TWENTY SIX.
MRS.
AB BARRIER THAT WE'VE SEEN WITH
OUR FOSTER YOUTH WE THINK THIS
IS A REASONABLE ACTION TO HELP
PARK FOSTER YOUTH COLLEGE
STUDENTS. AND LASTLY LOOKING TO
CREATE A NEW PROGRAM FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS WHO ARE
INELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL WORK
STUDY PROGRAMS.
THIS NEW PROGRAM PROVIDE UP TO
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR
FOR STUDENTS WHO DO VOLUNTEER.
WORK COMMUNITY SERVICE WORK AYE
WILDLY ATTEND COLLEGE IN
CALIFORNIA.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THE
FINANCIAL EIGHT.
pPACKAGE.
YEAH.
EXACTLY PULL ITEMS THREE AND
FOUR OUT AND. WILL BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT ONE AND TWO OKAY.
SO I'M MOVE UP. WILL APPROVAL OF
ISSUE THREE STUDENT AID BUDGET
PACKAGE IS ITEM ONE AND TWO.
OKAY.
SECOND. SECOND THE MOTION A
SECOND.
MCCARTY I.
CHAVEZ.
I.
LIMON.
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
OKAY.
NOW IN MOTION FOR THE.
.
FOR THAT CAL GRANT EXPENSE OR
FOSTER YOUTH.
AND THE.
.
THE.
CALTRAIN BE INCENTIVE SERVICES
GRANT PROGRAM.
VIOLENCE.
MOTION TO SECONDS HIS FATHER
MCCARTY AYE CHAVEZ NO.
LIMON.
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
OKAY.
THAT CONCLUDES
TODAY'S HEARING ACTION ONLY AND
WE WILL GET THEM BACK.
WE GET A BOOK TOGETHER THAT'S
RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT AND WE CAN
GET YOU TO COME OUT OF HERE IF
YOU LIKE ALONG WITH MISTER MARTZ
WHICH.
THAT CONCLUDES TODAY'S HEARING
WILL BE BACK TOMORROW WITH PROP
NINETY EIGHT DON'T.
SO SHE CAN ADD ON ACT